what's up everyone we are back in the
Veen Jane we're gonna be talking about
the personalized action plans that we
get from volume from understanding our
gut ecosystem and also what we can do
with all this data yes so it's very
interesting is that know we talked about
the technology what is matter
transcriptomics then we talked about how
we can actually make illness optional
and not going to talk about actually how
we make recommendations that are based
on your personalized gut ecosystem right
so as you can understand that why um is
the only company that does a functional
microbiome test so every company's
either doing a 16s we talked about
completely useless stuff matter genomics
stuff that doesn't tell you what the
microbes are doing and you what you
really need in the matter transcriptome
it's technology that tells you what is
going on once we know what is going on
what we do is now there are three things
we want to make sure that you are able
to produce lot of the stuff that your
body needs the good nutrients such as
short chain fatty acids the vitamin K
and the vitamin B and all the enzymes
and peptides that your body needs and
you want to minimize and eliminate the
stuff that is really harmful to your
body such as Lippo polysaccharides and
the other things that are causing
inflammation and really that is the key
of keeping this thing how to and the
last thing obviously you wanna increase
the diversity of your gut microbiome
because the more types of microbiome you
have both in terms of texture anomic
side but really more on a functional
side that means more types of things
they are producing the better we are
that means
the more different ways they can produce
more different things the human body
will step up better so what we do is we
look at the stuff and saying if you were
to eat think of your gut as a computer
and we're looking at when the input
comes to that computer this algorithm
that exists what would come out of it so
we look at the stuff we know what's here
we know what's what they're doing and
then we can change the input so we say
if you give the different input which is
different food so if I give you almonds
what's gonna happen when the Owlman hits
your body here's you versus what's right
so we did a couple of things number one
thing we did was we did it 1,000 people
test all of them we actually put a
continuous glucose monitor on their arm
and then we gave them fifty five
thousand to seventy five thousand
different foods just to see based on
their gut microbiome what how does their
body responds in terms of glycemic
response the glucose level how does it
think changes the glucose level in the
hosts by understanding what's happening
in your gut and by doing that now we
build a complete machine learning model
that tells us when you eat almond what
is going to happen when you eat carrot
what's going to happen when you eat
grape what's gonna happen when you eat
this particular food how does your body
is going to respond in terms of glycemic
response to glucose response that's one
part second part we look at the stuff
and saying we have the food ontology for
every single food and we see if this
food contains this chemical what how
would this chemical be converted by you
gut microbe I just wanna understand that
the glycemic response that you're
measuring for these people that also
your you have a meta transcriptomic over
there
yes microbiome as well so then you're
able to relate what's going on there
you've got equal system to there clay
similar spot absolutely correct thank
you for pointing that out so we are
looking at the matter transcriptomics
and we're looking at what is being
produced in your gut and how does it
relate to the response of glucose
response on the body right and by doing
that now we can predict every food how
your body is going to respond to it
that's one part the second part is
understanding the ingredients of every
food and the chemicals inside the food
so if you if you're gonna eat spinach we
see spinach has oxalic acid what would
happen to that oxalic acid when they
hits a gut is it going to be detoxified
into something benign or
is that going to actually end up as a
kidney stone because there is nothing in
your gut that can detoxify so our
recommendation will be try to minimize
or avoid this is spinach yeah right
instead eat the following things yes
right second part of the things are the
things that are actually good for you so
things you want to eat that maybe
antioxidative now you look at the food
that are antioxidative they are not
antioxidative in themselves they have
ingredients that can make those foods
into antioxidative so such as
pomegranate juice
it has allergic acid allergic acid is
not antioxidative but when allergic acid
is converted by the enzymes in your gut
it converts into you la uro lethen a
that is antioxidative so if you
organisms are not producing the right
set of enzymes that can convert this
allergic acid into ula you're not gonna
get any antioxidative benefit from these
food and that is the best or this will
end up being causing inflammation I love
how you are breaking down exactly what
the ingredient what the ingredient is
within the food yeah what it is and then
also something else that I find really
good about the volume platform is that
it makes it very relatable for you to
see which foods and what amounts of that
food like you were saying earlier avoid
or minimize or worse have as much as
yeah this is you want and that is a
direct relation to your gut ecosystems
ability to intake that food is how like
you said what input are you putting into
the computer and that is really our food
recommendations are all based on real
science that can essentially tell you
and that's a reason
thousands and thousands of people now we
have tens of thousands of people who
have actually done this and we amazing I
mean to me the most satisfying thing I
get is emails I get every day you
changed my life
I had joint pains I no longer have joint
pain I used to have acne it's gone my
eczema is gone my you know up I am lost
weight I
now sleep all night have never been able
to sleep you know all the conditions
that people call chronic diseases they
were simply the symptom we don't why um
doesn't diagnose any diseases we don't
claim to cure any diseases interesting
thing is all we do is reduce the
inflammation in your gut by balancing
your gut and when we balance your gut
the things we used to call diseases
those were the symptoms the symptoms
seems to go away we don't cure any of
these symptoms this should have never
existed to begin with we just fixed the
root cause yes
inflammation is a flame inflame the
flame that's burning we shut the wall
off gas wall yeah and once we shut the
gas wall the flame goes away and
suddenly your red skin is starting to
become normal rejuvenating then yes okay
so now you we use tens of thousands of
people now have went through vironment
we have all this data yeah now this is
very interesting so with this sort of
like 95 percent difference between me
and you and our gut microbiome and then
if I eat a carrot affects me differently
than if s you potentially hey Dad yeah
and and yeah and the ecosystem is
different so okay so then there so
there's that and then and then you take
the sort of the the way that your the
way that you're just able to calculate
all of the all of the all of this
information and what it means moving
forward so tell us about that so
basically we take all of remember
hundreds of thousands of transcripts of
all the micro organism forty trillion of
them we take all of their transcripts we
take all of the information you provide
us in terms of what is going on inside
your body and then we feed all of that
into artificial intelligence and then it
starts to crunch and crunching crunching
crunch and say okay here are the foods
that you should really be avoiding here
are the foods that super foods for you
here are other foods you can have in
these
two DS and if you were to do that your
body will essentially stay in balance
and the AI is the key and this is why
I've been you know really on this
mission to solve this problem the only
way we'll be able to solve chronic
diseases that we have in a hundreds of
thousands and the millions of people
come together to understand all these
different guts and all these different
symptoms what is underlying things and
every single person who joins us not
only gets better themselves it
contributes back to the humanity for
everyone else to be better in fact when
you join today you make everyone before
you better and the people who dine
before you are making you better and
gonna make the next person better right
so everyone is contributing back into
the people who already join and
contributing further to the people who
will be joining and this is what I
really mean our pharmaceutical companies
have become parasite on humanity
humanity will come together to kill this
parasite called pharmaceutical companies
the best day of our lives will be these
parasites are essentially dead because
our mysterious medicine the food is the
medicine that's the only drug you will
need we'll go back to the thing what
Hippocrates says let food be thy
medicine let thy Madison be the food and
I really believe if we come together
we'll get to a point we will eliminate
suffering we will eliminate chronic
diseases as a matter of fact I would
argue that our generation is the
generation that is going to solve this
problem if our generation does not solve
this problem we are the generation then
we looked upon as the generation that
allowed our children and grandchildren
to suffer because we were too selfish we
were too self-conceited we're too self
egotistic that we couldn't come together
to solve this problem yeah and last bit
about data because I think this is a
very interesting point along the way is
just that with when when I when I submit
to volume its we have the general data
privacy rights also stuff that's
formulating so is it a co-ownership of
the data is it enough
mice when it goes into the AI algorithms
so first of all no individually
identified data no personally identify
card data is ever in the database with
the information completely separated
completely encrypted more than anything
else remember we are doing the RNA
sequencing unlike the DNA sequencing
your DNA never changes from the time
you're born to the time you die you are
any sequencing the basically what's
going on inside your gut is constantly
changing and adapting that means even if
somebody were to hack into it and
somebody were to beat the [ __ ] out of
you and take that [ __ ] and analyze it is
going to be very different in three more
in three months of four months so you
can go back and say whew that's your
poop now my point is it is it is the
data what it's called snap shot and the
snapshot is constantly changing
thanks a lot idea yeah in addition to
that of course we have complete HIPAA
compliance I mean we use the Amazon
HIPAA cloud and we obviously keep
personalized identifying information
from all the data we are not a health
company just to be sure we still follow
all the laws as it right what we're
awareness company we didn't have to do
it but we do it because we believe in
making sure that our customers believe
in us we only do this because we believe
we can solve this problem and Alan just
to be clear you know you know me I don't
have to start a company I don't have to
do this at all I could be enjoying a
beautiful life on some sunny warm island
the reason I spent so much at a my doing
it because this problem is what solving
and I need every one of your help to
help me solve it yes it's a problem of
keeping a strong and healthy gut
throughout life awesome thanks